several valley residents are frustrated
they tell us homeless people are
lingering around their neighborhood and
they're concerned about safety but
county officials say the issue is more
common than you think
[Music]
i get like worried sometimes i had my
house rob recently like four years ago
and i always like keep on the lookout
lily beth has been living in this
neighborhood near flamingo and rainbow
for over 12 years but says safety is
becoming an issue it just looks like
there's a lot of homeless people coming
in and now people that i don't recognize
or it could be throughout the whole day
you see people just walking around
residents say their concern is growing
as some families are housing homeless
people clark county says this is more
common than you think we have a landlord
program we'd love to get you formally
engaged because that way we also get
case management job training all the
other things to that individual
so we appreciate people's heart there
are about 113 landlords to house 274
households since the operation home
program launched last year according to
the county which they say is helping
minimize the homeless population
homelessness is a really complex issue
and people don't get into homelessness
overnight and it's really hard to think
you're going to get them out of it
overnight and it takes a really big
support system beth says while the idea
to help homeless people is great it
makes her and her family nervous because
of their safety and the children in the
area it's not just me that sees it you
know it's my family maybe other people
but they don't speak up
well clark county says the homeless
population is decreasing thanks to
donations from the community to programs
like operation home now there is a bonus
for landlords to join now if you're
interested we have all that information
on our website 8newsnow.com